joining us now Jay Schrader former  Raiders quarterback NFL quarterback also  UCLA quarterback let's talk about the  the offense on this team for the Raiders  39 rushing plays 34 passing plays that's  a little upside down from what the  league is doing but it worked today it  worked because the Run game was  effective early on on first and second  down and that's what they needed to do  they needed to get Josh Jacobs going  kept him out of those third and long  situations and that allowed Derek Carr  to be efficient in the passing game and  Derek Carr rushing the ball we heard  Josh McDaniels talk a little bit about  that and how effective he was as a  rusher in this game let's show you a  couple of his runs here one of them